dwayne johnson
aka the rock is the world's highest paid
actor for the second year in a row
with 87.5 million dollars in earnings
his star turns have grossed more than 10
billion dollars at the worldwide box
office
i'm what you call a nice cold can of
we'll pass johnson's origin story could
be an entire tv series in itself
oh wait it's going to be young rock is a
new tv series which tells his origin
story
born into a family of wrestlers he
struggled in high school
got cut from professional football teams
got into some trouble with the law but
ultimately found his way through
wrestling
his break onto the big screen was
actually through the small screen
he debuted in wwe then the world
wrestling federation
in 1996 where he quickly rose to super
stardom
on the heels of his worldwide wrestling
popularity he hosted
snl he was magnetic right after that
universal executives reached out to
offer him a cameo in the 2001
blockbuster the mummy returns
his performance was the movie's secret
weapon
it received so much attention that the
studio gave him his own spin-off movie
the scorpion king
which grossed more than 178 million
dollars on a 60 million dollar budget
solidifying him as a bankable studio
investment
little by little he picked up more
starring roles some
very much a detour from the tough guys
he was used to playing
how disappointing but as charming as he
was in a leotard
audiences missed seeing the old rock he
went back to basics
logging more action films in his resume
he also created seven bucks productions
which helped shape his image from an
actor into a polished businessman
his team touches on every aspect of a
movie he's in
there's a creative team production team
and digital team
and he promotes the hell out of his
movies one of the ways he's able to
command such a high dollar amount
is his social media following and the
way he brilliantly monetizes it
building in a social media fee for every
movie he's in
usually in the millions and when he's
not making 23.5 million dollars for
appearing in movies like the upcoming
red notice
one can find him on the small screen on
the titan games
or promoting his super successful under
armour line from which he earns millions
each year
or selling his own brand of tequila and
of course posting epic workouts
i got a job to do tell your mom i said
hi
and well what's a video about the rock
that doesn't use an image from his
legendary fanny pack days
you're welcome
you